Robert Baer for 21 years you were a case
officer with the CIA's Directorate of
operations what does a case officer do
with the CIA
a case officer is normally assigned
overseas and his sole objective really
is to go out and recruit sources people
who can tell us things go places we
can't go for instance Islamic
fundamentalism into mosques I can't go
into a mosque of 10 I'm praying so we go
find a [ __ ] recruit him say tell us
what's going on what are they doing
what's what's the Imam saying what's the
Sheikh saying in the case a Homburg it
would have been nice to have somebody in
that mosque tell us what Mohammed Atta
the presumed mastermind at the World
Trade Center was saying how do you find
agents who are willing to tell you what
people are saying inside those mosques
it's extraordinarily difficult and what
I found is it's just a lot of luck and
what it and just being around these
people and talking to them all the time
eventually you'll run across somebody
who loves the United States wants to
help the CIA wants to give us
information aside from wanting to help
the United States are there other
motivations money honey revenge both
work combination of all three so how do
you when you land on the ground you're
in a new country how do you get started
and getting connected in a new country
the first thing you do is you would
literally drive around for a month
straight to you know a city inside and
out the alleys one-way streets and then
you start moving out and spend as much
time as you can on the streets talking
to people in stores buying things
joining clubs till you know a city
inside now which cities did you spend
most of your time in Beirut in their
favorite
so I have how did you get connected in
that city specifically at the time I was
in Beirut we were looking for the
hostages and most important thing for me
is find somebody in his ball are close
to his Bala and those four Shia Muslims
since we were assigned to the east side
because it was so dangerous the
Christian side I just looked for Muslims
I'd ask my Christian friends God
drinking the only Muslims anybody come
across look the green line which
separated the two cities and eventually
people start percolating up until you
find somebody it's a hard work it's
discouraging at times you go success
ratio usually we used to say that if you
had a really good recruitment one a year
you're doing well give you insight
information at that time about the
Soviet Union about Hizballah about any
terrorist group Abu Nidal there's a
photograph in your book of you as a
young man in 1977 and you've just begun
your training with the CIA how old were
you in this photograph was a private 23
or 24 was about ready to jump out of an
airplane and you can look at that
photograph there's the welder but my
face like what am I doing here why am I
gonna jump out of this airplane so how
did you land in the CIA how did you come
to sign up with the CIA I was fast it
was a mystery to me I wanted to get the
doctor was something behind the walls
they look into and I thought it'd be
great to look and spent a couple years
and go do something else and then it
it's stuck then I love to work was it
what you expected when you stand up no
course not but the longer I stayed in
the more I liked it and the more I liked
doing the job I actually liked spending
time with my agents or with my contacts
or going out more than with anybody else
with other Americans so you did you
become obsessed with collecting
information what's the biggest risk that
you ever took there weren't too many um
in Beirut everyone saw something shoot
at you not not intentionally showing
but yeah we don't the CIA isn't about
carrying guns and shooting out the bad
guys and you know you know it's nothing
like the movies we're supposed to be a
little gray man who go out and listen to
people and never be heard from and never
be seen presumably your friends and
family had no idea what you were doing
all those years when you left the CIA
were they surprised I never told them I
mean this book's gonna be a shock to a
lot of people what did they think you
were doing I had a cover which they've
asked me not to talk about for a good
reasons and in the book I don't I don't
mention it have your friends and family
found out now and if they start asking
you questions about it yeah what sorts
of questions do they have for you why
did I write a book why am i going public
why did you write a book it was a great
story people kept on telling me I would
sit around my my colleagues and I said
is my stories what happened the last 20
right he said guy that'd make a great
book it's a great story as a beginning
and an end in a middle and if you could
only write this to make a fabulous book
I started two years ago with a co-author
the voice was wrong though it wasn't my
voice because I wanted to put all my
mistakes in and you know the ups and the
downs and what it was really like you
know it's almost like Forrest Gump you
know you're in the CIA lost in the CIA
and I saw all these things and it made a
good story and I like I like this
version a lot better because as you've
seen there's you know I've made a lot of
mistakes like what's an example of one
of your mistakes the funniest was when I
went up to baalbek 1984 which is the
last circle of hell the bottom circle of
hell
and I thought I was just going to go up
and take a look around with some friends
we're going to protect me
and then leave but then they announced
we're going to lunch and we went to
Hussein almost saw Wiis house one of his
cousins and the guy asked me my name and
what nationality I was I was not
prepared for it at all with my mistake
and I said oh I was Belgian he's name
says oh that's interesting he says
what's your name
I said Remy and it's Remy is that your
family name I said Remy Martin before I
could stop myself of course you know
introducing yourself as a cognac Myles
and fundamentalist was not it was no
swift move did most of the people that
you ran into have some idea that you
might be CIA when you're abroad and
there are many Americans around were
they suspicious when I was in Iraq they
that they knew obviously that I wasn't
normal a ID person or anything like that
because carried machine-gun places like
Paris they had no idea who I was you
know could turn a conversation off I'd
say I was I don't know a CPA or
something like that you know doing an
audit or something nice conversation too
long
he'd make your cover up as you went on I
got better I stopped introducing myself
as a cognac after all what did you think
about the process of writing a book I
loved it I loved it I wrote over and
over and over again I wrote with my lamb
he sat by me and I'd sit six or seven
hours rewriting trying to find the right
word showing it to people getting people
to read it was hard finding an agent was
almost impossible / how did you find one
in the end a friend um said call this
guy up take a piece of writing I showed
it to him he told me go write her
proposal he cleaned the proposal up just
go back to write the book he got six
months to finish it your book came out
shortly after September 11th undoubtedly
that's generated more media interest in
the book are you doing a lot of media
and connected in a lot of media with ABC
CBS's can do a program
O'Reilly Factor that's all been lined up
I've lost control of the whole thing do
you like doing media that's okay I mean
it's not used to it I spent 21 years
hiding my face and the shadow and all of
a sudden I'm talking about things I was
never an actor but um I had to do it to
write the book and sell it I just
thought it was a great story and people
have enjoyed it in the course of the
book you reveal your increasing
disenchantment with the CIA why did you
become disenchanted I wasn't that's a
hard question it's not question being
disenchanted with the CIA is that when I
joined there were a lot of swashbucklers
and I liked those people got along
better you know hard drinking hard
living out doing things Beirut was a
wild place over the years I stayed the
same and the CIA changed it became more
of a state organization more
bureaucratic call of what you will it
wasn't the CIA's duty to change to suit
my needs and so on when I was in to
change it was time to leave and I
resigned to write do something else why
did the CIA change I think as you know
the old congressional commissions did a
lot of damage
it made the CIA risk adverse even
through the 90s they were there trying
to clean the place up I think Americans
wanted to cleaned up
they'd mistrusted the CIA were there
specific events that there's Guatemala
there was an American killed there mrs.
Harbury Park a member have brought a
case against the CIA and
there was Vietnam was Bay of Pigs one
one scandal after another
Chile Congress started looking into the
place and the managers had no choice but
to comply and how did it change I think
it became risk-adverse
when people read this book in the CIA
the managers they're going to call me a
rogue I call a calculated risk I never
got caught I never lost an agent that's
all I care about
I never broke American law but I got
results from time to time did the CIA
start trying to rein you in I think they
looked at me with amusement and didn't
quite know where I was going on the Iraq
when I was investigated by the FBI for
trying to kill Saddam it was the White
House that started the investigation and
the people in the CIA were as helpful as
they could be without annoying the White
House they gave me a medal after I left
I know the director I went to school
with him I think he was always sort of
amused by me he's well-liked and I was
never mistreated in the CIA what's the
story about trying to kill Saddam
Hussein I was in northern Iraq and there
were two separate groups of one to do a
coup d'etat against Saddam he got very
close the White House sent us a message
pulling support 36 hours before which
caused it to collapse had they been
supporting it to that plant I I think
that if if there have been public
diplomacy supporting a change of regime
in Iraq it might have succeeded in this
case it didn't it collapsed we came back
to Washington my team there were five of
us five Americans and a rumor had
started that
someone in northern Iraq was trying to
assassinate Saddam Hussein which wasn't
true but once that rumors started in the
White House picked it up Tony Lake
called Louis Freeh the FBI director and
said investigate these people at that
point the CIA had no choice but to turn
us over to the FBI and we were
polygraphed we were all cleared
eventually received a certificate for
our work in the north so it came out
okay is it fairly typical that there are
those sorts of checks within the CIA yes
anytime there's a problem inside the CIA
automatically called justice in the FBI
they did they're over cautious of them
if an employee has there's a presumption
he's done something wrong they call the
FBI and Justice the CIA has given up
policing itself I did when I was it may
have changed to Simpson do you think the
CIA could have prevented the terrorist
attacks of September 11th I think that
if we'd been more aggressive in Europe
and not worried about what the Europeans
were thinking about and gone after
Islamic groups we had a better chance
and I think today that that's been
reversed I would imagine who do you
think is responsible for those attacks I
am convinced it's groups inside Saudi
Arabia under the umbrella bin Laden and
I still think they're in Saudi Arabia
and they will let will attack again even
if we get bin Laden what what sort of
danger are we in now and what do we need
to do to prevent future attacks
aside from strengthening of government
FAA FBI
we should have national identity cards
keep track of foreigners I'm very
liberal person but you have to do these
things when you're faced with the
terrorist threat we have to have
national identity cards with chips in we
have to keep track of foreigners that
come in the country do we have agents on
the ground now who can who are scouting
out the right people those agents that
you were talking about earlier inside
organization
that you were trying to find do we have
enough of those people who can assist
the CIA we don't have enough I'm sure
now but they will one day it takes a lot
of time takes it takes eight years to
make a case officer you get two years of
training two years of language probably
three years of a first-tour to learn how
to do the job and that takes that takes
us to seven years but it takes a long
time what sort of training is involved
explosive jumping out of airplanes
recruiting how to make microdots
how did it run clandestine
communications my good looks a little
tiny negative that you can implant for
instance I could implant it I could cut
this paper and implant it under the S so
I could send you a book with a little
photographic negative you would know it
was on this page 124 you'd know is under
the S you pull it out and put it under a
reader and reading whatever the messages
but it would take a hostel service
forever to go through a book they don't
know what it was
they don't use microdots of morning but
the old days they worked if you receive
a lot of military training to more
familiarity with explosives guns things
like them what do you think is the most
important quality in a CIA case officer
for me flexibility living foreign
environments you have to spend basically
whole life outside the country you can't
be a case officer for two years then
come back to Washington spend the rest
of your career you have to spend 25 to
30 years you're giving up a lot you're
giving up your family you know parents
die you're not there you miss because of
whatever
so now that you've left the CA what are
you doing now I'm gonna see if I can
teach myself to write I don't what I
don't know how this books gonna be
received um write a novel do you have
another you have a plot in mind sure as
a secret I can't tell you have you ever
written a book before this one
no I've written memos for 21 years never
tried to write a book but you like you
like the experience it's worth repeating
yeah I like telling the story the
stories in three parts people tell me
it's a page turner self does the climate
of the CIA change depending on who's in
the White House no no you know a lot of
the conservatives would like to blame it
on Clinton or blame it on Gore or
whomever or door john deutsche former
director or george kennan it's the CIA
is operating under strict guidelines
that were set down in the since the 60s
by congress you cannot blame it on one
person to what extent does public
sentiment influence the way the CIA runs
it supper it's strong I don't think that
most Americans particularly like to
trust the CIA are like it they remember
the scandals in your in the writing of
the book you had to show the manuscript
to the CIA in order to get it approved
for publication but did you take it to
them did they come to you how does that
process work
I sent the manuscript to them they
looked at it for about a month they came
back and this was the first version the
one that was done an anonymous
fictionalized partially fictionalized
they cut out about a third of it and
they said you can't use this this and
this and I said that's fine
cut that down tried to rewrite it I
started with an adversarial process
but once I calm down they calm down and
we work together very well what sorts of
things did they cut out of course the
names of agents there's no description
in here that you could identify an agent
they cut out what sort of cover you know
if you work for State Farm Insurance or
you work for the bureau engraving and
printing
they don't want that in there we took
that out they took out classifications
by other agencies White House
classifications were taken out they said
we can't declassify White House
information I found the people at the
publication Review Board very
sympathetic frankly I'm surprised as I
read this book I was surprised that it
was published at all because there are a
lot of sensitive things in here and a
lot of names and dates and places were
you surprised that I was that through
some of them the the the names I put in
here are the names of the people who
were conducting terrorism against the
United States I was very surprised I
think there's there's parts of this book
er strong indictments against people
that should be brought to jail this is
the finished edition of the book and
they're all these mark outs here these
are names and phrases once some of these
passages were taken out did you find you
had to do a lot of rewriting I had
certain assignments in certain places I
went which they've asked me not to
mention so I had to write around them
when I was in the traveling the Bekaa
Valley I wrote around that Simon but it
was no problem and I left the blackout's
in simply because I want people notice
this book is factual this is not
fictional and that
that if I could tell the whole story I
would have added a line here and there
we're going to go now to a tape of you
reading and the audiobook version of see
no evil here in DC at a studio and the
passage that you read begins with a
description of the kidnapping of Bill
Buckley who was Bill Buckley Bill
Buckley was the chief CIA chief in
Beirut
he was kidnapped in 1984 and died in
captivity he was kidnapped he was
kidnapped by Iran and probably died of
pneumonia after being tortured do we
know who kidnapped him yes
Ahmad McNeil who's on most-wanted list
now he's probably living in Beirut still
to this day well thanks very much for
talking thank you for much for having me
book TV videotaped Robert Baer last
November as he read part of his book see
no evil for an audio version of the work
the following edited portion is a little
less than a half hour at 10:38 a.m. on
March 16 1984 Bill Buckley the CIA chief
and Beirut was hit over the head on his
way out of his apartment building pushed
into a car and driven away no one got a
plate number a description of the
kidnappers the ijl or Islamic Jihad
organism no one got a plate number or a
description of the kidnappers the ijo or
Islamic Jihad organization one of the
groups that claimed responsibility for
the Embassy bombing one of the groups
that claimed responsibility for the
Embassy bombing eventually would claim
credit for Buckley as well but that
didn't tell us anything we still didn't
know anything about the I Jo Buckley
wasn't the first American kidnapped in
Lebanon since the 1982 Israeli invasion
in addition to Dodge Frank Reggie a an
American professor of electrical
engineering at the American University
in Beirut Frank Reggie a an American
professor of electrical engineering at
the American University in Beirut had
been snatched in February 1984 CNN
bureau chief Jeremy Levin
had been gravity month earlier CNN
bureau chief Jeremy Levin had been
grabbed a month later but those were
civilians this was a family member
loaded with secrets I've got to go back
to the Bekaa and see Olly John I said
John looked at me as if I'd finally lost
my mind during the next seven months not
a single lead surfaced on Buckley not
only did we not find out who kidnapped
him we weren't even sure he was still in
Lebanon the CIA tapped every government
and private source it had to find him
but no one could tell us anything not
even a plausible rumor as for myself I
was convinced Baalbek was as good as
places I need to start looking and the
more I brooded on the kidnapping the
more certain I became that would get in
and out safely
eventually curiosity got the better of
me the first thing I did was to arrange
to meet name blacked out an advisor to
name blacked out let's let's get an
adviser to just as if that's the end of
the sentence it sound like us going
elsewhere just that last phrase and
invade an advice an advisor to name
blacked out
a branch of his family that had settled
in the Buckeye a branch of his family
that had settled in the Bekaa lived
peacefully with its Shia neighbors
including the masami's the drive to
Baalbek was like descending into hell
just outside of town lurid menacing
murals were painted on the sides of
bombed out buildings one was of
Jerusalem's Dome of the rock mosque the
third holiest site of Islam bursting
through an American flag
another was Ayatollah Khomeini leading a
demonstration against the American
Embassy in Tehran a third an American
flag spattered with blood and just it is
Khomeini is that Khomeini yeah it came
up with a hard K do you want to do it
yeah another was Ayatollah Khomeini
leading a demonstration against the
American Embassy in Tehran good that's
fine
in Baalbek itself banners written in
Farsi and Arabic draped across the
street proclaim death to America that's
I might talk back was open three South
again in Baalbek in Baalbek itself
banners written Farsi and Arabic draped
across the street proclaimed death to
America the captain took me to the
temple of the Sun when we knocked on the
closed gate to the old Roman section of
Baalbek the gate swung open and there
were two guides khaki uniform Iranian
posture on soldiers they couldn't have
been happier to show us around the site
we were driving out of town when I
casually asked the captain about the
compound on the hill which I knew was
the sheikh abdallah barracks he stopped
the car by the outside perimeter wall
and I had a chance to take in all the
buildings it was remarkable how
different they look from the ground than
they did from satellite photography one
building in particular caught my
attention to posture on soldiers
regarding the front door in either
cardboard to posture on soldiers
regarding the front door and either
cardboard or blankets cover the inside
of the windows a wooden sign on the wall
identified it as the married officers
quarters Robert just to safety please on
the gets about six lines down or five on
the gate swung open and there were our
two guides can they from there to the
end of the sense
okay the gate swung open and there were
our two guides khaki universe safety
place the gate swung open and there were
our two guides khaki uniform Iranian
posture on soldiers right thank you it
wasn't until years later that I would
learn Bill Buckley was inside as I look
blindfolded and chained to a radiator
along with five other Western hostages
nor would I know for certain at this
gate no nor would I know for years that
this is the same bill nor would I know
for years that this same building was a
key link in my search for the embassy
bombers but in truth I wasn't really
surprised by either revelation
everything in the Middle East is
interconnected pull on one thread and
the dozen more pull out will pull on one
thread and a dozen more will pull out
but you've got but you've got to have
human intelligence to do it
people on the ground agents access
agents a network of spies or traitors
that should be true spies a network of
spies with them stakeout the traitors
but you've got to have human you but
you've got to have human and most are
you moving ok but you've got to have
human intelligence to do it people on
the ground agents axis agents a network
of spies and a case officer willing and
able to work it no aerial reconnaissance
photo could have put together the
covered windows and guarded no aerial
reconnaissance photo could have put
together the covered windows and guarded
door at the sheikh abdallah barracks in
the end intelligence boils down to
people I think the CIA knew that back
then the spirit of our founding fathers
still lived in the agency but it
wouldn't be long before we were running
Pell mell in the opposite direction with
disastrous consequences from the Middle
East to find the America's own soil
Langley Virginia January 1986 the G
quarter on the sixth floor looked like a
construction site boxes for
coils of telephone wire and trash were
piled up everywhere the offices on
either side of the hall were swarming
with electricians and painters
construction crews were ripping up
floors tearing down perdition's and
putting up new ones tearing down
partitions tearing down partitions
construction crews were ripping up
floors tearing down partitions and
putting up new ones no one had any idea
where the new counterterrorism chief's
office was I had to go from room to room
to find him when I did though there was
no mistaking at singularity for starters
cigar smoke hung in the air like
low-lying cloud for starters a cigar
smoke hung in the air like a low-lying
clouds we pick up top the pitch again
please okay for starters cigar smoke
hung in the air like low-lying cloud for
starters cigar smoke hung in the air
like a low-lying cloud thick enough to
close down most airports unlike most
everyone else in the CIA Dwayne Dewey
Claridge didn't believe in desks instead
there was a round table with a half a
dozen chairs pulled up to it in the
middle of the smoke of it instead there
was a round table with a half dozen
chair instead there was a round table
with a half a dozen chairs pulled up to
it in the middle of his small office an
informal atmosphere encouraged younger
officers an informal atmosphere
encouraged younger officers to wander in
and talk
Dewey figured the best ideas percolated
up rather than down do we perhaps didn't
need to worry about the trappings of his
office because unlike most CIA officers
he was plugged into the White House as
head of the Latin American division he
had cut every corner he needed to to
help Ronald Reagan's beloved Contras for
good measure in November 1985 he had
also expedited the first shipment of
arms to Iran
Dewey's Dewey was the White House is
kind of spy it didn't surprise anyone
that after Abu Nell's
Christmas 1985 it didn't surprise anyone
that after Abu Nidal is Chris
1985 attacks on the Vienna and Rome
airports the White House tapped Dewey to
head a new CIA counterterrorism unit one
with teeth the White House tapped Dewey
to head a new CIA counterterrorism unit
one with teeth as soon as he saw me as
soon as he saw me standing in his door
Dewey motioned me to come over and sit
down next to him at the ground table
Dewey motioned me to come over and sit
down next to him at the round table
I'd heard enough about him to know where
I'd heard enough about him to know there
was no point in beating around the bush
I want to work in terrorism mr. Claridge
I'd be happy to take any job I want to
work in terrorism mr. Claridge I'd be
happy to take any job two weeks later I
was drafted into Dewey's new
organization the Counterterrorism Center
or CTC my first few months serving as a
foot soldier in Dewey's war against
terrorism was about as exhilarating as
it can get in the spy business do we had
a new presidential finding authority to
pretty much do anything he wanted
against the terrorists right there
accorded authority to pretty much do
anything he wanted against the
terrorists he had all the money he
wanted the CIA director bill Casey
promised him a carte blanche to
cannibalize the do and the DI for
anything he needed to stock CTC for
anyone Casey this is the new the CIA
director bill Casey promised him a carte
blanche to cannibalize the deal in the
DI for anyone he needed to stock CTC
Dewey even recruited a handful of Los
Angeles cops he was planning to deploy
them around the world and start hauling
in terrorists and handcuffs does that
work yeah we're good okay
by the time I started ctc's new offices
were miraculously up and running
it was pure frenetic energy every what
everyone worked in one huge open bay
with the telephones ringing non-stop
printers clattering files stacked all
over the place CNN played CNN playing on
TV monitors bolted the ceiling hundreds
of people in motion that their computers
you had the impression of a war room
right there hundreds of people hundreds
of people in motion and at their
computers you had the impression of a
war room one more safety piece hundreds
of people in motion at and at their dead
hundreds of people in motion and at
their death acum hundreds of people in
motion and at their computers you had
the impression of a war room
expectations were high everyone had
heard about doing successful
counter-terrorist operation when he was
head of the European division one of his
offices helped run an agent in the
lethal Palestinian terrorist group known
as the may 15 organization that
specialized in airplane bombs the agent
was a gold mine providing information
that stopped a couple of terrorist
attacks and do we had no intention of
losing of and do we had no intention of
providing providing information that
stopped a couple of terrorist attacks
and do we had no intention of losing him
when the agents may fifteen boss ordered
him to attack an American target duty
craft when the agents may fifteen boss
ordered him to attack an American target
do he craft in an operation which the
CIA exploded a car inside an American
embassy compound in such a way that the
agent could take credit no one was
killed but the agents boss was convinced
the agent had tried and he continued as
a fantastic reporter for us all of us
new recruits expected all of us new
recruits expected operations like that
to be the norm in ctc but it wasn't long
before the politics but it wasn't long
before the politics of intelligence
undermine everything do we tried to do
all those CTC look like a high tech
command center the truth was that Dewey
had no one to command in spite of bill
Casey's promises the CIA office in spite
of bill Casey's
promises the CIA's offices abroad still
answered to their Geographic division
Chiefs back at headquarters and as the
division Chiefs made absolutely clear
clear and as the division Chiefs made
absolute and as the division Chiefs made
absolutely clear not one of them was
interested in fighting Dewey's war it
was too risky a botched or even a
successful operation that's right
they're botched a boss a botched or even
a successful operation would piss off a
friendly foreign government someone
might be thrown out of his cushy post
declared persona non grata someone might
even get killed
we'd ask Paris to put together a
surveillance team to watch the apartment
of a suspected terrorist and Paris would
come back and tell us it wouldn't and
Paris would come back and tell us and
Paris would come back and tell us it
couldn't because the local intelligence
service would find out
we'd asked bond to recruit a few Arabs
and Iranians to track the middle-east
emigres community in West Germany and it
would respond it didn't have enough
officers once we asked Beirut to meet a
certain agent traveling to Lebanon and
refused because of some security problem
security was not security was never not
a problem in Beirut for God's sake
instead of fighting terrorists we were
fighting bureaucratic inertia an
implacable enemy an implacable enemy do
we didn't even have the do we didn't
even have the carte blanche to recruit
staff that he had been promised after
six month he couldn't after six months
he could put his hands on only two
Arabic speakers another officer and me
but since the other Arabic speaker
managed a branch that left only me to
travel and meet agents that wasn't a lot
since about 80% of CTC that wasn't a lot
since about 80% of ctc's targets spoke
Arabic there were no Persian Pashto or
Turkish speakers at all I was assigned
to a branch task with finding the
hostages in Lebanon but I was the only
one in the branch with any experience in
the Middle East the branch chief had
never set foot in the Middle East let
alone Lebanon my first shot of rat my
first shot of reality came early about a
month after my first shot of reality
came early about a month after I joined
CTC bond cabled at a leader of the
serious bond cabled drink order bond
cabled that a leader of the series of
Bond cable that a leader of Syria's
Muslim Brotherhood who was living in
Germany wanted a meeting with the CIA
the Muslim brothers are also distant
cousins of the Wahhabis of Saudi Arabia
a sect known for its puritanical version
of Islam heavily backed by the Saudi
royal family which they helped to keep
in power the Wahabis spawned Osama bin
Laden they also served as the
inspiration for the Taliban faction in
Afghanistan
I'd had some experience with the mothers
I'd had some experience with the Muslim
brothers during my abbreviated tour in
Khartoum one of my jobs there was two
words blacked out against Muammar
Qaddafi's there's yeah we need something
in its bed too
one of my jobs there was two words
blacked out against Muammar Gaddafi one
evening soon after I got to Khartoum I
invited two Libyan distance a political
boss and a military commander over to my
apartment for tea as usual the
electricity was often there was a
sandstorm we sat in the dark sweating
and talking about the normal things you
use to warm up a conversation with Arabs
right there we um I'm sorry
he's out in the dark uh yeah we sat in
the dark sweating and talking about the
normal things you used to warm up a
conversation with Arabs marriage
children in the price of bread the
military commander finally came around
to talking politics he mentioned passing
that he'd been able to quickly rebuild
the group's military cadres in Libya
after its failed May 1984 attack on come
actually I didn't quite get in passing
he mentioned in passing um okay
he mentioned in passing that he'd been
able to quickly rebuild the group's
military cadres in Libya after its
failed May 1984 attack on Qaddafi's
residence even though most of the
attackers had been killed right there
even though even though most of the
attackers had been killed I asked the
military commander why he thought he
could take Qadhafi in a place so well
defended God told us to do it god yes
he didn't add without the slightest hint
of irony he told us the day an hour that
set off bells at least am i when we
start over again that set off bells at
least in my head these Libyan distant
these Libyan dissidents hadn't been
build in Washington as Muslim brothers
but when they told you God called the
shots there was certainly a good chance
the Muslim brothers were nearby
I was curious now and I had to wait
I was curious now and I had a way
check on my suspicions when I was
studying Arabic in Washington I ran into
a Sudanese graduate student who worked
nights at the front desk of my apartment
building just as I had with the
Palestinian student earlier I would sit
with my Sudanese friend for hours
practicing Arabic in return I helped him
with his English one in return I helped
him with his English me too that he came
in return I helped him with his English
one night in a heart-to-heart talk he
confessed he was a Muslim brother he
explained to me the group's ideology its
commitment to changing any Muslim leader
who had fallen away from Islam he
believed the Egyptian jihad an offshoot
of the Muslim brothers was legally
justified in murdering Sadat Sadat was a
NAPA state he said and the Koran
mandates that app estates die my roof
rent my friend returned to Sudan about
the same time I arrived there and we
renewed our friendship when I asked him
about the Libyan distance he confirmed
they were Muslim brothers right there
when when I asked when I asked him about
the Libyan dissidents he confirmed they
were Muslim brothers noting that his own
organization backed them to the hilt I
knew that dealing with the Muslim
brothers was playing with fire
these guys were programmed for trouble
but if the Reagan administration really
was determined to fight it out with our
enemies in Syria and Lebanon you
couldn't find better surrogates the only
question was what they were prepared to
do for us and to find that out you had
to talk to them do we agreed that I
should do we agreed that I should meet
with them and I was on Monday and I do
we agreed that I should meet with him
and I was on an airplane to Frankfurt
the next day the plan for me was to wait
by a designated kiosk in the Dortmund
railway station until I was signaled by
a Brotherhood cut out not the best of
arrangements but since bond wasn't going
to help I didn't have a choice at the
stroke of two a dark bearded man with a
paunch about 45 years old walked up to
me and without saying a word motioned me
to follow him we were heading toward a
side exit when he pulled me by the arm
into the baggage claim room the baggage
handler who had also the baggage handler
who also looked like an Arab nodded
my bearded escort as we set off between
a long row of baggage wrecks and out a
back door to a rear loading dock waiting
there were two identical charcoal gray
Mercedes with smoked windows we got in
the backseat of the first one after a
short warm up through Dortmund the two
Mercedes turned onto the Autobahn it
opened up their throttles all the way we
never got out of the fast lane which in
Germany is reserved for drivers who
think 120 miles an hour is a prudent
speed about 20 miles later just as I was
getting used to the German version of
NASCAR the driver swerved abruptly right
cutting diagonally across the two slow
lanes without ever easing off the gas
pedal and dropping down an off-ramp I
hadn't even seen the Mercedes took what
looked to be an aimless route through a
new modest scrub German suburb by now it
was early afternoon almost no one was on
the street when the driver turned into
the driveway of a house identity all the
rest and almost almost no one was on the
street when the driver turned into the
driveway of a house identical to all the
rest and pulled into a bottom floor
garage as soon as we were inside the
door closed behind us I would never have
been able to find the place again if I'd
wanted waiting in a small office
adjoining the garage was a frail elegant
man with a neatly trimmed beard he was
in his late 50s I guessed wearing a soft
gray flannel suit and a starched white
shirt with a straight collar he struck
me as particularly calm and collected
the concept doesn't exist in Islam but
the word that came to mind was beautiful
be it if ik is a beatific I believe so
let's just get one as an alternate okay
the concept doesn't exist in Islam but
the word that came to mind was beatific
for the next hour the muslim brotherhood
leader vilified the regime in Damascus
he described Hafez al-assad as a heathen
the incarnation of evil and in other
terms you didn't hear even in Washington
where acid was never there and in other
terms and in other terms you didn't hear
even in Washington where Assad was never
where Assad was actually there's little
noise in there one more end in other
terms and in other terms you didn't hear
even in Washington where Assad was never
particularly popular finally I
interrupted and asked what could be done
the man smiled we are ready to go hand
in hand with the United States and
remove this cancerous or from the god
site
from God site how'd she get we are ready
we are ready to go make my talkback
something okay we are ready to go hand
in hand with the United States and
remove this cancerous or from God one
more one line we are ready to go hand in
hand with the United States and remove
this cancerous or from God's sight how I
asked suspecting the worst we have
buried in Guto near Damascus Airport a
sa-7 missile he said matter-of-factly as
if he told me he planted in bed of
petunias in his garden back home what we
need is your help to inform us when
assets plainness about ready to take off
and he is on it my first thought is a
case offers was damn this was hot
information What did he say an he said I
am a nice day yes I said
yeah I guess the sourcing couldn't be
better
this men was a boss in the Syrian Muslim
Brotherhood and he was talking about
capping Hafez al-assad the biggest
hurdle to a Middle East peace since what
our new friend was proposing wasn't just
pick up the biggest hurdle the biggest
hurdle to a Middle East peace since what
our new friend was proposing was an
assassination in violation of executive
order one two three three three
I'd have to report to Dewey but still I
hope that we could keep meeting this guy
and maybe redirect his energies to
something we could work on in common
even if we couldn't I didn't see any
harm in keeping open our lines of
communications to him who could tell
when he might need the Muslim
Brotherhood who could tell when we might
need the meet Muslim Brotherhood in the
future one who could tell when we might
need the Muslim Brotherhood in the
future back in Washington doing litt
back in Washington Dewey listened
carefully as I told him about the
meeting go write it up he said wait he
added as I was heading out the door
nothing on a computer use a typewriter
instead destroy the ribbon afterwards
and don't make a copy I want to keep
this between Ali unit view I want to
keep this between Ali you and me Ali was
Oliver North the NSC staffer who would
take the fall in the complicated
interplay of missiles hostages and
funding for the Nicaraguan rebels that
became known as the iran-contra affair
as instructed I gave duaa the only copy
of my contact report the last I was ever
to hear about it as for bond it was
unimpressed with the cable I sent as for
bond it was unimpressed with the cable I
sent it about the meeting - the part
about the sa-7 bond stuck to its
original position that it did not want
to meet anyone from the Muslim
Brotherhood I didn't have the time to go
back and the CIA would meet the Muslim
brothers again but Syrian orgy dropped
it you want that in or not Syrian Muslim
brother yeah we can put it back in I
didn't have the time to go back in the
Syrian I didn't have time to go back and
the CIA wouldn't meet the Syrian Muslim
brothers again but the Muslim brother
I'm but the Muslim brother I met in that
in
but the muslim brother i met in that
innocuous suburban house in Dortmund
would pop into my life again in the days
after September 11th 2001 when the FBI
came calling to tell me that one of the
Syrians associates was a suspect in the
global network that had supported the
tax on the World Trade Center and the
Pentagon all right can we keep that when
can you pick up safety please when the
FBI came calling when the FBI came
calling to tell me that one of the
Syrians associates was a suspect in the
global network that had supported the
attacks on the World Trade Center and
the Pentagon break it yourself a two
minute break okay mouth starts getting
tired you know speak speak speak you
know it let's just rest it for a second
ah sometimes the two-minute break is
really great